go
oh here we go they both got this
identical movement
this is
gonna get it
[Music]
this just in
a speed drinking German man broke the
Guinness World Record for how fast he
was able to drink a Capri Sun what's the
time
10 seconds with a straw what does that
sound like that seems yeah I feel like
that sounds slow it seems easy right
dude the suction on these things I can
do it in check this out seven seconds
because it's it's it has to be a Capri
Sun like it can't be water like this
specific one is about Capri Sun all
right okay yeah I think it's it's pretty
fast 10 seconds is fast yeah 10 seconds
is fast
is it through the straw yeah because of
how long it is I was gonna cut it
because we have a friend but he does
that throw you know
just go it could pour like you could
drink as fast and then just hook
instructions down huh yeah okay that's a
Guinness World Record look at that
number the initial record I feel like
three four one so exactly like on
average it'll probably be like 30
seconds as the fastest dude I'm telling
you right now I can do it less than 10
seconds I have I grew up with [__] my
brothers and sisters and you gotta hide
it you know what I mean yeah yeah yeah
[__] three seconds is there a
technique we're gonna find out
[Music]
I'm running
jump of
[Laughter]
is it cold it's got a timer oh yeah
one by one let's do one by one yeah yeah
one by one pizza dude here's here but
can we have the can we have this no no
don't don't touch anything here's the
trick can I drink it slow it's 10 it's
10 point 10 seconds 10.41
from this point
oh [__] out of here that changes
everything I knew there was like it does
change everything if I can't even take
the straw out can't take the straw you
gotta do it everything do you have to
put the straw in or can you suck it from
the hole Yeah
yeah baby if you if you could do that
and you can empty it it's gonna be
harder to drink all of it because you
have to drink all of it I'm not even a
good fast drink right well it's too cold
I like this app so we're gonna go first
time and see where we stand against the
record damn yeah
one at a time
who's starting first what table are we
gonna go clock
yeah yeah
[__] oh my God first of all get rid
of all that porn go right here
[Laughter]
you guys know where the timer is so just
so you know the record that this guy
beat was 15 seconds wow okay wow so it's
like 15 or uh yeah 15. do you have to
poke it in this hole yes or can you poke
it anywhere I think you have to poke it
in the appropriate hole
because that makes it bad you might
break your straw honestly I don't think
you gotta do the [__] Olympic
standard the right way yeah whatever
whatever the rules is for this [__] yeah
true okay okay okay I'll go first okay
first we're gonna start with Cameron
we're doing the regular one already you
can't be touching it oh what ready hey
this is regular rules through the whole
second yep traditional style two one go
oh my God this is already hard
yeah get in there
21 seconds damn
that's a long time I felt like forever
dude you're a good sucker how's your
brain freeze it's too cold
not bad 21 seconds
I'm off by ten Ten's pretty freaking
hard that was fast dude I want to see
the video the guy doing all right guys I
guess I gotta go tell me when yeah put
your hands like so uh go when I say go
okay three two one go all right let's go
let's go let's go [__] [__]
no
no all right he's on this praying out
though oh
geez well he has to drink it off the
table come on Joe you're gonna have to
finish those drips dude yeah do you
gotta lick the table oh
25 21 seconds
[Laughter]
it's the [__] straw you're gonna go
on go okay one two three go go
oh that's good that's a good shot damn
it why is the hole okay um
okay you're good yeah you're really good
oh suck suck suck
oh
come on come on come on
almost
dude 19 seconds crazy right now
19. it is cold dude it's cool the stupid
straw can I warm this please there's got
to be a strong technique that he knows
can I put it in the microwave part slows
you down for sure ready yeah three two
one go
oh
excuse me
bro let's go oh [__] he might beat the
15 seconds
[Applause]
so he matched the old record
oh dude damn
that's 15 8. all right Nick you're up
what you got man should we do it
together
all right wait wait I'll uh I'll time it
and whoever's the first done I'll say
off and then you'll do the second done
okay cool okay
um
you're doing this one mm-hmm okay ready
three two one go
[__]
the [__]
holy [__]
[Applause]
say done when you're done
oh my God
he's got 15.98 for Nick
[Applause]
come on brother
22 for 22
.
there's still liquid in there yo we do
we should do a [__] death message
dude
that was great
this game we used to drink a lot of
Capri Suns huh
it was a goddamn straw are you ready
yeah
death match three two one go
oh here we go they both got this
identical movement
Jesus is waiting no he's gonna get it oh
we got it oh oh
[Applause]
God
you're just casually drinking he's still
going
by the time Nick got a straw in
damn dude
I poked her too hard Jesus poked it too
hard
let's go baby we're back you would have
beat the old record dude Jesus with the
14 points
damn baby that was amazing you would
have got a second place Guinness record
what's actually in a Capri Sun I'm all
hopped up right now bro dude I feel like
I could see me do a [__] hey whoa
It's pear grape and orange juice
concentrate damn it monk fruit
concentrate wow it only has half as much
sugar pineapple juice content because
they use a monk fruit what's monk fruit
hey there's mushroom extract in here too
so it says that um the Guinness World
Record rules are uh it's the time it
takes to remove the straw from the
plastic sleeves stab it into the pouch
and and drink the whole thing just like
what we did yeah dude dude
yeah if I stopped having sex and did
this for real oh this guy what did he do
this is the guy who broke the record is
there a video yeah what did he do what
did he do that's him doing it hold on I
want to see from the beginning what's
his technique
it comes down to the straw I gotta see
he takes it out he bites the straw yeah
so ready to go
oh he already took it off yeah
I think we need to see the whole thing
dude that is that's just because the
straw [__] is this wow that was pretty
fast so that is that's crazy it was a
good time it's the time yeah dude I
could do it in [__] 10 seconds took
me five seconds to get the straw out
yeah
dude I got adrenaline coursing through
my veins right now
foreign